hurt people hurt people a lie that is
far overused but so [ __ ] true when
someone is hurt instead of actually
looking internally and finding a way to
fix whatever the [ __ ] is going on in
their minds in their world they like to
hurt people they want to bring people
down to their level so when it comes to
bullying nobody that is intentionally
trying to hurt your feelings is happy
period And I believe that as if it's a
fact if someone is happy they're not
behind a computer screen they're not
face to face intentionally trying to
tear someone apart when someone's happy
they have goals when someone's happy
they're inspired when someone's happy
they generally just want what's best for
everyone